in terms of the story and ripping it
wide open in a relationship it also
signifies and I'm speaking of your film
Anderson bench someone who's awoken to
to maybe how their life was going and
then they see it in a new way for the
two of you having both been in LA at one
time how freeing is it to be now in
another part of the country where do you
feel more creative and some sense
because there's less of the LA hustle
and bustle are you able to then
formulate stories or ideas and a
different pace or different rate I think
you should answer first I'm because
mine's different than that sure a lot of
the ones a lot of the movies were making
I think I still I still lived in Los
Angeles when I wrote Anderson bench but
I didn't want to I was I was somebody
who wanted to get out wanted to escape
escape from LA because I felt put upon
and I felt judged and condemned and
trapped and all those things at Anderson
bench feels so once I got out of here
and moved to Louisiana there is a there
is a it's a lot freer there and it's
interesting in that there's a lot of a
lot of politics going on everywhere at
the gas station at the if the county
seat I mean there's a lot of stuff going
on in Louisiana that's probably going on
here but we're unaware of it as we're so
far away from Sacramento but I find it
to be a very a very feeding place
creatively but I don't feel as nearly as
they say you can't really sing the blues
and so you've had them I'm very happy
guy now when I wrote these when I wrote
Anderson bench I was not a very happy
guy I was like writing Anderson bench
and
like that and now it just makes me laugh
i watch Anderson bench and it's it's
freeing it's freeing for me but I do
prefer I prefer the the atmosphere
sitting on the back porch and in
Louisiana with the cypress trees and the
cypress knees and the frogs I find that
to be much more personally fulfilling
personally feeding and I write different
kind of things when were there yeah
different definitely changed yeah which
is great it's a new perspective for me
filmmaking has come full circle there so
originally I came from Louisiana worked
my way into LA and through the system of
independence and always have done
independence that walked our you know
beat to a different drum and then
finally worked my way into the studio
system and then really felt like there
was door slammed constantly in my face
but Louisiana for me definitely was full
full circle starting off initially in
the film industry there and telling
stories there so it's a different
perspective yeah and you know there's
nothing that I hope it never doesn't
sound like we're pooh-poohing the studio
sister yeah I understand why the studio
system is what it is I mean and it's
there's nothing wrong with it it's a
it's a corporate creative mentality it's
more business than show that's why they
make so much money I mean I understand
that and I don't fault it at all it's
just never been I am NOT a corporate
personality she is not a corporate
personality we have never been that in
times where we've had to have been
broken and shoehorned into a corporate
kind of a box
we have tolerated it at best but it's
not our personalities we are destined to
make very loud mistakes I am anyway yeah
absolutely
which the only people who succeed I
think in life in anything are those who
are willing and apt to make very loud
mistake
so there I grew that okay cool
you